hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play ray
alright people starts coming out of the
walls but I'm ready farm
I want the hat what is that that looks
like something that I want need I don't
like this but I am a rock I will
persevere shoot it
Peter panting is way into my face get
away get away get away get away get away
get away
that's right
[ __ ] right off oh oh
grabbing about you man
I swear these monsters are worse than I
imagined this came true
ha if I had to take on that guy like out
in the open I don't think I would have
made it was just
not another please not another one of
those things like anything put one of
those exact I don't even know if it can
take on the flying guys give me
something give me something give me
something cuz the ammo is black in it
I think it has glowing whatever this is
drill hello
okay we got here nude or red lines 22
okay I think it's a map I think the red
spots might be items or weak walls or
something that I drill through okay this
is buried for charge I don't think that
battery recharging this doesn't tell me
where I am those
hey okay maybe it's this ah that's it
okay that would explain why I got come
on nothing no ammo please ah the baby oh
baby oh baby baby
the metro station was different somehow
nothing I could put my finger on but
everything seems slightly off it was as
if the entire building had rotated just
a couple of degrees areas that I
remembered walking through were now
closed off leaving me unable to shake
the feeling that some unseen force was
guiding me down pathways to a
destination I had no way of knowing
trying to put my best narration on to
those in the vents
lovely exactly what I wanted I hope no
babies pop out in front of me
okay
seems halfway decent so far I'm not dead
yet yep for ammo I got to be careful
with this one actually picked my shots
try to nail headshots another one okay
pick my shots nope okay very yeah
can't float up here Kenya Wow
what was that oh did they have an anti
get on table device oh they probably do
okay alright anyway come on I guess it
was another one like a little kid
skating how do I get that kid
sugar sugar sugar sugar sugar yeah
didn't hurt yeah you tried her I
actually let myself go a bit too much
down holding down e is much more better
you were to me no bullets spamming ears
often as I can I hope I don't miss any
yeah how about that that's cool ominous
no I can't reload is die thank you I
don't even know how many bullets are in
this thing all right I guess I guess
there are more bullets in here than I
thought like the what you have is just
an extra actually you know what I don't
want to know I don't want to know don't
be dinging
oh man this game is literally so
atmospheric I can't even describe it
music look really cool too I mean they
put a lot of work and a lot of love into
this yeah that's right back off okay
pretty alright you two boys you kidding
me what what what yes there we go okay
yeah so this gun holds 12 bullets
remember I'll be home soon
just half an hour more 10 minutes before
before
I'm a big baby
I'm embarrassing myself what am I gonna
do with four bulls I could even kill
anything with four bullets ah where'd
you come from
what the hell with that why'd you just
go zooming past me what was that all
about
yes and whenever I'm able to autosave
the quicksave I spam tastic we say what
is going on here that's what I want to
know Oh headshot on whatever the hell
that was
what gives there are so many oh oh oh oh
oh oh that is so freaky oh oh that is so
freaky oh you guys look at that for a
second haha that's another one
oh no gimme I don't know what that's all
about but that's freaky anyway I need
something to stand on give me something
stand on anything anything you'll do
anything will do
yeah yeah man just go white but took
time yeah oh hey I could I guess I could
have gotten on here but that might have
been a bit too risky nothing else man
these things brutal I don't think those
I don't think I'm quite ready for that
oh I see yeah boy left
I bet I do
Oh can I come alrighty how did I miss
that I still can't tell how the thing
works with the batteries I mean been
using my flashlight pretty much non-stop
damn you man Oh anyway I've been using
my battery pretty much non-stop haven't
done any diminished quality over time
thank you
bullets oh I don't know why it comes
clips of 14 but I'm not really
complaining you can only load 12 but
this oh I see yeah you're a doll hey
doll yeah
is that the only thing in here
now I go through the door with the
board's I bashed up here here here here
there here where is it where is it
where's the thing I did this fish is
looking tarp I'm onto you see what's the
deal in there why is this the only
barrel that you can't go through
mmm fishy
clues vicious maybe I'm busted up I can
take that but still I don't unless I
missed something which is very possible
probably likely no I don't see anything
okay we're okay back it off going on my
own merry little way wait a minute wait
a minute something changed
[ __ ]
okay
I always do damn oh did I just quit save
their maybe I don't know I don't know
she's gonna kind of approach that a
little differently yeah there you go
buddy okay all right maybe I saved after
but okay anyway so I'm all out of time
so thank you all so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
part but I